>>LE
JUSTNDENT EVAN PERHEAN, WAH HAPO
IT WAS VERDRAMATIC
PO GREENBERG'S ATTORNEY I'NOW,
VERY COMFORTABLE TODAY.
REENBERG, A COUNTY FOR
OFAL DOWN THERE IN THE
ARHE'S FACING  OCHARGES,
INCLUDING SEX TRAFFICKING,
G A POLITICAL POINTEE,
FRAUD.
AND HE KWS ABOUT MATT
RDING TO SOURCES WE TWO WERED IN
NUMBER OF INCEERE
FWREENBERG HELPED ARRANGED FOR
A THAT GREENVE HAVE SETHNGRESSMT
MAKING A PLEAIS LAWYER, I
AG THE
EEER ERHAPS, PERHA- WE DON'TT PN
A PLEA AGREEMENTMR.
THAT IT WILLW A SENSE OF
RSE, WHICH HE DOES HAVE, A  ACC
ON
UNIQUELY SITUATED.
OT
FEOMFORTABLE TOD. >> ANDHIS AN
LF, WITH THA
VET AS YOU HEARDOK, I THINK IT'R
WH MAKA PL AGREEMENT
THAT THE GOVERNMENT PE
TO PROVIDE SOME COOPERATIO
CHEEING -- FORSUPPORTING PERHAP
SENTENCE.
MOMENTDEEDIFICANT, VERY DRAMATIC
YOU'RE ALSO LEARNING, EVAN, THAT
FEDERAL INVESTIGS
LO TP THAT
SSMAN GA TO THE BAHAMAS AND
PAIDO TRAVEL FOR SEX WHIM D OTH.
SOURCES? YOU HYOUR
>> RIGHT,
ILAW COME
TRAFFICKING, PROSECUTIVE BEEDER
VETHEORY THAVENG IS AT CONGRESSF
OM THESE TRI AS WELL AS ENTS FO
SEX WITH HIMN EXCHANGE TICAL FA
FROM OTHER MEN, OTHER
OTHER POLITICAL FIGURES IN
FLORIDA.
THE CENTERY, VERER OF LE
BIG ANG ATION,
WOLF.
AND THIS TRIP TO THEAMAS IN
THE LASTR OR S AMONG THE
IGATORS ARE G INTO.HE IDEA THAT
TRAVELING TO HAVE SE
AGAIN, ONE OF THE THINGS THALDO.
SCRUTINY FOR IS POIAY NG AP WIT
GIRL W WNLE ME, BUT THERY OTHER
O IS.WOLF?
WE ONNOTTLE BIT OF WHAT WAS GO
RIGHT NOW.T WE SHALL SEE, SOONER
PROBABLY RATHER THAN LATER
EVANTHANK YOU H.LET'S GET TO MO.
I WANT TG IN THE STATE
ATTORNEY FOR.
GAETZ I
COMFORTABLE TODAY.GR WITH THAT
>> DEFINITELY,
GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
SURIN TH J
TO KT A DEAL WITH FEL
PROSECUTORS.
O DO SO.
S FACING AENTIAL
SE
AND AT LEAST A
TING TO THSACHIL
GAETZ INFORTUNATE TH
THERE A
BIGGER FISH TO FLIP
T ONLY DOES HEW WHERL DIES ARE O
WHRES HE WT THE SAST ONE TO
TO THE THE LAST TO E E
BECOS DINNER.
EEG'O SAID
HIS CLIENT, AND I'M QUOTING NOW,
WE KNOW HE AND WERE TH
ND P AS. INFORMATION
BERG
E?
SHAPEE  GUILTY AND FULLY COOPEC
OGAETZ.
>>.S VAG NEWS FOR GAETZ.
MA GAETZ'S DEFENSE INU
H S, HE HAS NEV HAD
WITH AN
ONY COULTALLY DESTROY THOSE DE,
ESPECIALLY I
ES
WHEN IT COMES TO SEX
LAWSO
BROAD, PFU
SEE  HARSH, SO
TALKING ABA VERY SERIOCRIM
YOU DON'T EVEN NEESE
WI MINOR.
GIRL T GREENBERG.ETZ ENTICED
IT'SUG FOR THE
HOTEL ROOM.
IT'SUGID
WITH THE DRUG ECSTASY.
IT'S ENOUGH IF HE ST TTH A H
HER TTEL.
ANY OF THOSE THINGS UL
ND POSSIBLY
CONVICT MATT GAETZ OF CHILD SEX
S  PLEADS
TO GET A RLLY COATERL FOWO
GET AEDENTENCE,
RIGHT?>> CORCT
HE WOULD GET ATE
AN WM THE
NOT BE
E IN THE DOO B
TARGET AS IS.SO, YEAH, MATT NE
SW TO DECAF.NY MOMENT, FEDERAL
OFFICIAL COULDT  W
FFS.HAS BEENG A
LOT OF SINCE JOEL
GREENBERG WAS ARRESTEDAS
YEAR.
AS THE INVESTIGATION HAS LEEE M
FO
MACHINE.G WACRIME
HE'S LIKE THE PERFECT PERSG UPO
LIFE I.
ANUTF IT